it's an exciting time for our president
Donald J Trump has begun his massive
tour through Asia first stop Japan
the mysterious nation to the east an
ancient world of cherry blossoms kabuki
and fruit corrupted by geometry now I'm
a bit worried about this visit you see
president Trump is our most America
first asset and any exposure to foreign
cultures could dilute his pure American
core but thankfully he's got protection
aides have tried to do everything they
can to keep the president's schedule so
that he remains engaged to try and keep
things familiar yes for example no whole
fish with the heads on I'm still
remaining to keep the president in his
comfort zone
yes keeping David trumpet his comfort
zone is priority number one which is why
Paul Ryan is coming along as his human
footrest but just because Trump's in
Asia doesn't mean he'll be seduced by a
bunch of Asian stuff he's too smart to
get tricked by a foreign power and he
proved it on his first day with Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a look at this they
lunched on hamburgers played nine holes
of golf and fed koi fish at the Akasaka
Palace they signed Hans custom made for
this day in bright gold letters it said
Donald and Shinzo make alliance even
greater yeah right there right there you
see how powerful he is Obama probably
went there was like bowed and he took an
interest in their culture that our boy
he goes to a new place and bends their
culture to his will America first style
you want to deal put it on a hat puppet
so America and he spreads americanist
wherever he goes he's like a patriotic
rash
these Japanese are so lucky they got a
massive dose of pure uncut trumpet ood
and Americans are so jealous you can
tell because as soon as he left the
country his approval ratings hit an
all-time low we missed your pop-pop
that's why we are watching as every move
in Japan and I got a say oh what a show
president Trump's presidential Ness is
raging overseas right now he's juiced
this is the strong leader we fell in
love with boom look at the jacket the
hair well Trump is pure sex and he's got
that hot rhetoric to back it up as the
president arrived in Tokyo his first
order of business was rallying the
troops stationed at Yokota Air Base we
dominate the sky we dominate the sea we
dominate the land and space yeah that's
all of them yeah it's like everywhere we
jammed our flag into the moon in the 60s
and the moon hasn't dared attack us
since drops just letting Japan know how
we roll
flexing our AmericanMuscle Japan is a
warrior nation you already had Donald
Trump according to the the the Japan
Times newspaper make comments that he
couldn't understand why a country of
samurai warriors didn't shoot down North
Korean missiles force comment/question
drugs right Japan is a nation of samurai
warriors in fact they don't even need to
shoot down missiles they can use the
ancient art of I hope I'm pronouncing
this right fruit ninja let me
demonstrate
Edea launch the missiles
see people of Japan it's that easy
[Applause]
[Music]